is there also differences by individuals
who prefer morning night and then maybe
as well in terms of not just the hours
of sleep but the time of the day in
which you sleep this comes back to a
concept biologically well defined called
your chronotype so are you a morning
type evening type or somewhere in
between depending on the data it's about
a third third split across the
population I am unfortunately just like
the rest of my pedantry uh in terms of
Personality I'm desperately boring I am
completely vanilla I'm a neutral I'm
sort of like an 11 to 7 kind of guy but
your chronotype as to when you want to
go to bed and wake up
it's not your fault
and it's not your choice
because it turns out that it's
genetically determined and we now know
that there are at least nine different
genes that will dictate your morningness
versus evenness preference in terms of
being a sleeper what we call are you a
night owl or are you a morning Lark it's
gifted to you at Birth it's hardwired
and it's very difficult to change and by
the way if you want to know truly what
type you are you can go online and you
can search for something called the meq
which stands for the morningness
eveningness questionnaire for chronotype
and it takes about three or four minutes
really easy and you get your type
um you can also do it in a quick fashion
you can just say look you know if you or
I were on a desert island nothing to
wake up for we had we could go to bed
whenever we really wanted to and
whenever we really desired to wake up
rather than when Society forces us to go
to bed and wake up what time would that
be and for most people that time owes to
when they would like to go to bed and
like to wake up is very different than
what time they actually are currently
trying to go to bed and trying to wake
up which suggests that modernity has
inserted a wedge of a mismatch in terms
of our sleep timing based on our
chronotype because Society is
desperately geared towards and biased
towards morning types you know it's this
the early bird catches the worm those
are the people that are praised that
leaves out in the cold and chastised
wrongly so as if it's their choice the
evening types
and the early bird may catch the Worm
but I would also say that the second
mouse gets the cheese
and so you know there's there's lots of
ways that we should be much more kind to
ourselves and others in society
regarding evening types
the Practical part of it comes to people
that I'll see at my sleep center here
who will say look I am I just have
terrible
insomnia I have difficulty falling
asleep I go to bed and I'm just wide
awake for the first hour I just cannot
fall asleep and then I'll ask them a
little bit more about their chronotype
and it turns out that there's someone
who at the weekend finally they would
normally be going to bed about midnight
1am but during the week because of their
schedule of course and understandably so
they're forcing themselves to get into
bed at 10 pm
which is a two to three hour difference
relative to your natural chronotype so
no wonder your biology is not even yet
ready to try and help you fall asleep
but you're sitting there in bed just
wishing it to happen and you can't wish
for sleep to happen and make it it's not
like a light switch in that sense and so
it masquerades almost like what we call
a form of sleep onset insomnia there's
also something called Sleep maintenance
insomnia so do you have difficulties
falling asleep or difficulties staying
asleep and they're not mutually
exclusive by the way but people with a
chronotype who are a night owl they can
sometimes have that challenge they're in
bed too early and they can't fall asleep
that's probably one of the most
important points to discuss today
because as a primary care physician
obviously insomnia whether it's the
start of sleep or disrupted sleep not
being able to fall asleep afterwards
upon waking in the middle of the night
um
it's easy for me as a physician to
either look it's just a lifestyle
changes talk about sleep hygiene discuss
caffeine usage alcohol usage things that
would impact sleep from my training
level
and maybe even mental health like that
would be a step further that I go that
most Physicians probably don't even get
to in their 15-minute visits
unfortunately in our current health care
System
um but should we be as Physicians
thinking about chronotype more
I think we should certainly be asking
that as part of the equation and being
sensitive to that in terms of
understanding it it turns out that
there's a whole field of um
chronobiology and Chrono pharmacology
because it as we've now started to
understand drugs can have different
potencies of effect
on the basis of different times during
the 24-hour cycle and there may be more
or less potent times for you to provide
that medication you know sometimes for
hypertensive medications some evidence
that um time of day is important there's
a big field demonstrating that cancer
medication can have a chronotype
dependency non-trivial in terms of its
efficacy so I think that that's
important
um I also you know I love the way that
you think about not just going to sleep
hygiene which is critical
um and be mindful of alcohol which is no
friend of sleep and caffeine equally so
and then moving to mental health because
what we know is that perhaps one of the
biggest
common central pathways through which
your body instigates this thing called
insomnia is having an overactive fight
or flight stress system
um within the body which is part of your
um the automatic nervous system it's
called the sympathetic nervous system
it's anything but sympathetic it's very
agitating aggravating It's the
fight-or-flight branch together with
something called the HBA axis which is
part of your hormonal axis particularly
regarding a hormone called cortisol
which is a stress related hormone
and when those things are switched on
which sort of high levels of anxiety
worry and stress will very much do sleep
is almost impossible and it results in
people the phenomenon that I would
describe as tired but wired where they
are so desperately tired but they're
just so from a mental health perspective
to your point they're just so wired that
they can't fall asleep and until you
actually Target the treatment of the
mental health component it's going to be
very difficult to I mean you one could
just simply offer you know sedative
sleep agents to try and knock the cortex
out but we know that there are
increasingly better ways and I think
one of the things that Physicians have
Maybe started doing is becoming aware of
the the current recommended alternative
to sleeping pills which is something
called cognitive behavioral therapy for
insomnia or cbti for short
and I would say that for any sleep sorry
for any general physician any GP who is
facing a patient who is saying that they
are struggling with sleep trying to at
First Direct them towards cognitive
behavioral therapy for insomnia and
trying to find a provider for that I
know it's difficult it turns out if you
look at the number of people who can
provide it there is a mismatch between
demand and Supply there's not enough
supply for the demand nevertheless being
aware of cognitive behavioral therapy
for insomnia is critical there are now
some apps that you can use as well to
help with that to make it more
convenient that's the only thing I would
add to that equation
yeah absolutely I'm a big proponent of
CBT I even have been able to Institute
some introductory I wouldn't say their
introductory sessions but maybe
um
um basic understandings that I can pass
along to my patients until they're able
to see a mental health provider about
women is how it works where we work on
thoughts as opposed to feelings because
in reality the Mind Body Connection is
so much connected that we give it credit
for that patients oftentimes are ready
to get a physical diagnosis and are
really surprised or even shocked when
everything comes up normal the Imaging
the lab tests and it's only until we get
to their mental health do we figure out
that's where the problem is at least
beginning and then showing itself
powerful you know to think that you know
a physician in this day and age and I
know I'm not pointing anything as I the
job that you have is so immensely
difficult Within These compressed zip
file time periods you're supposed to go
through this complex biological organism
in front of you quickly make make a
diagnosis understand the treatment path
outcome prescribe and get a you know so
that someone like you is being already
able to think about cognitive behavioral
therapy and then give the stepping stone
components to help them on their Journey
as they start to seek out that further I
mean how much better would the world be
you know if that was more common
practice I can't imagine
I think it would improve health outcomes
significantly that's why I'm a big
proponent of increasing funding for
primary care because like the struggle
that a lot of Physicians have is those
15-minute visits with patients that are
unknown to them that they don't have a
history with like the Urgent Care model
where a patient comes in to see a doctor
they've never seen before and somehow in
15 minutes this Physician's supposed to
create a rapport with this patient learn
about their condition their symptoms
um potentially connected to some sort of
cause
create the treatment make sure that the
patient understands the treatment they
can afford the treatment they have
access to the treatment and then
document that entire interaction in 15
minutes on what planet and then make
sure the insurance approves that right
right you know what do we what are we
doing if we're if our goal is to try to
care for other human beings in the most
medically sound way possible so
um you are I mean Heroes uh to keep
doing that and thank you for what you do
thank you I appreciate you saying that